turning now to the political fallout
from the supreme court leak roe v wade
lawmakers on both sides of the aisle
have some big decisions ahead if the
court overturns the landmark ruling ed
o'keefe is following this and he joins
us from the white house ed good morning
good morning natives the biden
administration and democrats now try to
take action to protect abortion rights
it's set to be a major issue in this
false midterm elections with the
president saying voters now have a clear
choice to make
democrats across the country are now
under pressure from abortion rights
advocates to take action after that
bombshell leaked draft majority opinion
shows the supreme court could soon
overturn roe versus wade if anybody
kicks you out of the constitution you
got to think about how you're going to
get yourself back in planned parenthood
president and ceo alexis mcgill johnson
talked about taking action wednesday
night on the daily show and she's not
the only one the supreme court doesn't
have to have the last word
in the senate democrats are planning a
vote on making abortion rights federal
law
the united states congress can act and
protect a person's right to an abortion
but the mainly symbolic vote is unlikely
to pass but you don't have the votes for
it by making people vote on this issue
that matters to so many people
we've got a chance now maybe to change
the makeup of who's in the united states
senate and i'm all in on that fight if
the court rules as expected abortion
regulation reverts back to the states
each of those elected representatives
can make the decisions that they view
best for their constituents mississippi
is at the center of the supreme court
challenge with its ban on most abortions
after 15 weeks but if roe vs weight is
overturned it's one of 13 states with a
so-called trigger law prohibiting
abortions immediately with limited
exceptions people in our state believe
that when a woman chooses to have an
abortion that she's not only making a
decision for herself she's also making
the decision for that unborn child
president biden is now warning of what
could come what are the next things that
are going to be attacked
because this mega crowd is really the
most extreme political organization
that's existed in american history
in recent american history
the white house says it's exploring
options for what it might do once roe vs
wade is overturned but doesn't want to
preview them until or unless the court
actually overturns that original ruling
and in more fallout from the leak of
that draft majority opinion they've
boosted security over at the supreme
court putting up fencing overnight and
justice alito who wrote the draft
opinion canceled the scheduled
appearance for today at a legal
conference in nashville tony
more fencing in the nation's capital not
a good look ed thank you very much